being born different isn't a bad thing
at all
just look at what these brave people
have accomplished all in the name of
self-acceptance if you are a first-time
viewer click the red subscribe button
and get ready to be inspired
today we are discussing 10 people with
rare diseases who will inspire you
suffrage ralph when he was just a
toddler souffron ralph and his family
emigrated from haiti to new york city
having humble beginnings did nothing to
stop the young model ralph suffers from
a skin condition similar to vitiligo
which causes freckles all over his face
and body
he was once bullied for his skin
condition but at 21 he's made a career
out of modeling
when he was 13 he began his journey in
the modeling world and hasn't looked
back
he says he's thankful for his freckles
because they make him unique and he
hopes to keep cashing in on his looks
for years to come
lizzie velasquez since she was a little
girl lizzy velazquez has had to deal
with people laughing at her because of
her appearance
the now author and motivational speaker
suffers from a rare congenital disease
as well as marfin syndrome
the disease she has causes her to age
prematurely and have extremely low body
fat
similar to neonatal pro-droid syndrome
she is in her twenties but has had the
same body weight as an average
eight-year-old
she's used her life as an example of not
letting your outside appearance define
who you are on the inside
she is now a motivational speaker and
hopes to keep spreading her story to
raise awareness and inspire others
nick voyage just looking at nick
vouchage you can tell he is special
voice was born without all four of his
limbs and was given no medical reason
for his condition
because of this voyage spent his youth
being bullied so bad that he attempted
suicide at the age of 10.
he was suppressed with the hand he had
been dealt in life until one day he had
an epiphany that changed
everything he read an article that
motivated him to get in control of his
life and choose to be happy
he has since become an author and is now
an international motivational speaker
jessica cox when it comes to living life
to the fullest
jessica cox lets nothing hold her back
born without both arms due to a birth
defect cox has still been able to live a
full
and exciting life she is the first
armless person to receive a pilot's
license as well as being the first
armless person to receive a black belt
from the american taekwondo association
she's even able to perform simple
everyday tasks like putting in her
contacts or typing on a keyboard with
her feet her motivational speeches are
now a source of inspiration in 20
countries around the world
sean ross another model that is all
about self-acceptance is sean ross who
is regarded as the first professional
model with albinism
instead of letting his appearance get in
his way he decided to embrace his looks
and try to help others do the same
ross started the in my skin i win
movement which helps encourage others
who have felt hurt
because they look different he hopes his
movement will help people shape the way
they look at themselves which will
hopefully lead to self-worth and
happiness
ariana paige russell though her skin
condition dermatographia never really
held her back
ariana paige russell wanted to turn her
irritating flaw into a work of art
dermatographia is a rare skin condition
that leaves ariana's skin hypersensitive
so it gets red and swollen when
irritated
it got so bad that her friends would
tease her for how easily she turned red
she eventually went to her doctor and
got the non-life-threatening condition
diagnosis
she now uses her skin condition to
create works of art on her skin that
she's turned into wallpaper
videos and even temporary tattoos she
has also started a blog about her
condition to help others who are
struggling with the same
sir major growing up with albinism which
causes his skin to lack any pigmentation
was a struggle for sir major who is now
a model and actor
many people with this condition struggle
to see well which can leave them
unable to get jobs or even drive he says
he has had to work twice as hard but
refuses to live his life in silence
though he hasn't had any significant
campaigns or roles he was featured on
american horror story
and hopes to get more opportunity sir
major has overcome the odds but has
aspirations as big as the sky which he's
determined to accomplish one day soon
clara beatty while in the womb clara
baby's parents knew she would be a
different baby as a prenatal exam
revealed she had treacher collins
syndrome the rare genetic mutation
affects the bones and tissues in clara's
face leaving her with extreme face
deformities though her condition hasn't
affected any other aspects of her life
her parents worry it may become an issue
down the road
as of now clara has adjusted well and
only wants corrective surgery so people
will stop annoying her with questions
she loves to help others and even
volunteers with a special needs theater
chance smith chance smith hasn't had a
very easy life when he was 10 years old
he was finally adopted after living in
several foster homes
his new mother helped him through not
being able to do things like the other
kids
he set his mind on being an artist but
considering smith can't use his hands he
had to be innovative in order to express
his artistic talent
because of a rare joint disorder called
arthrogryposis smith is unable to use
his hands for tasks such as writing
or drawing he didn't let that slow him
down as he has become a great artist by
sketching and painting with his mouth
instead of his hands
chantal brown young you may recognize
chantal brown young who goes by winnie
harlow in the fashion world the young
model started making waves in the
fashion industry by appearing in huge
campaigns
what makes brown young unique is her
rare vitiligo which leaves large white
patches on her skin
she is so comfortable in her skin that
she hopes it becomes a non-issue in the
future
she wants to be known as a model with
the skin condition but she doesn't want
her skin condition to define who she is
do these people with rare diseases
inspire you react in the comments
section below and don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things